welcome back to the ground up show my
name is Matt dia Vela and today I have
two very special guests
Joshua fields Milburn and Ryan macadam
Asst better known as the minimalists
what's up man thanks for having us so so
you're saying the ground up show but
we're also going to cross promote this
promote post well I don't what I don't
understand any of the broadcasting
vernacular that's what we have Matt
maybe you can help me understand so
we're gonna we're gonna publish this on
the minimalist podcast as well and so
welcome to the minimalist podcast
everyone there and that's how you cross
posts that's easy we don't need to do
any track done every little see you
think that's me every little thing you
think that you need
every little thing that's just feeding
your greed oh I bet that you'll be fine
so as you guys know in this podcast I
talk with guests about their stories
their ground-up stories how they built
something from nothing
how they turn their lives around and
it's kind of interesting because we made
a documentary together called minimalism
and that's like our ground-up show
basically it's it's your story of
starting with nothing and and kind of
going the suit-and-tie corporate guy
nine-to-five route and then becoming the
minimalist so we can just transition to
the seventy-nine minutes of audio from
the documentary I'm just gonna cut out
Sam Harris and Dan Harris and then what
does nothing that you guys in it I gotta
tell you man I'm still upset that you
named this podcast the ground up show as
opposed to the initial accidental title
that you had when you first emailed me
you so I think about doing this podcast
and you're just looking to see some of
our best practices or whatever and and
you said because everybody because the
world needs another podcast I'm like
that's the perfect title that is a good
luck has one and I'm sure someone's
Lissa's us now they're already like it's
gone I gotta get that domain name yeah I
know all right I think it's a funny idea
and I've been using it as a tagline in
some of my videos right but I'm just not
sure if I want to commit to that as like
forever you know to me because when you
build something you kind of have to
stick to that name it's like pod castles
to Joe Budden's podcast and it used to
be called I'll name this podcast later
and I think it was like the first 120
episodes it was called I'll name this
podcast later and now it's just the book
Joe Budden podcast but so he did reach a
change he eventually changed it but I
loved the first name I'll name this
podcast later was perfect or because the
world needs another podcast was was
perfect so welcome to everyone to
episode number one of the world needs
another pot that's it that's it this is
the kind of mentoring that I need right
now
so I don't want to like cover everything
that we talked about in the documentary
and everything that you guys have
covered already though there's gonna be
a lot of overlap but I do want to talk
about entrepreneurship like how you guys
started the minimalist and how you were
able to turn that into something you do
full-time which is pretty incredible and
which is I think what a lot of people
would love to be able to do it's not
it's not like the only route the only
recipe that to kind of create your own
audience and build your own business but
it's certainly one that I think is
attractive to a lot of people so I do
want to cover that but before we get
into it can you guys as like a business
as the minimalist calm how do you guys
split up your duties and what do you do
like on a day to day basis I guess both
the the macro and the micro yeah I
everything is is 50/50 to some extent
but when you look at sort of the the
division of responsibilities but that
might mean some things like I was just
talking to Beck's my partner yesterday
and we just announced this Australian
tour and so we're headed to four cities
in Australia and New Zealand and she's
like I said I gotta stop I gotta stop
the car and we need to I neither like
respond to some emails there were some
issues with the ticket links or whatever
and because I manage our relationship
with our booking agent and then Ryan you
will manage other relationships so I
think a plan for us is quite often we
work together at least ostensibly or pop
when we're public facing but a lot of
the background stuff is like oh you take
this I'll take this or Sean takes it or
Jess will take it or have you do stuff I
mean we have a whole team of people who
we kind of yeah utilize and delegate and
kind of split responsibilities but I
mean if you look like if you look at
Sean Harding who I mean he's kind of he
was our first official employee you look
at his job title and it depends on which
day you look at it I mean one day he
could be our tour manager another day he
could be our Director of Operations the
next day he's our book editor the day
after that he's our website editor it's
just good to have a team of people who
can who were very versatile and could do
a lot of things and then we just kind
yeah throw stuff each other's way and
pick up stuff and yeah there's no
specific title or duties that I could
like to list off right and I think the
like what you touched on is there's a
difference between work that you do with
others like the collaborating coming up
with ideas deciding on whether to do a
documentary or start a podcast versus
sitting down doing the writing doing the
work mentoring and there's a lot of
stuff that you know it's difficult to do
as two people yeah I think the writing
thing is a good example of that I mean
we've written a lot of stuff together
but it's usually we're not like in the
same room together when we do it like
Ryan will come up with an idea and I'll
try to shape that into something or I
will write something and say hey what
are your thoughts on this or we'll have
a discussion about a topic and that will
manifest and are writing six months
eight months later because that that
idea often needs sort of like a
gestation period and so writing is
something that's often a very solo act
it requires solitude it requires for me
it requires early mornings it requires a
willingness to to sit down and put in
the work because for me writing is
really difficult and and it always
cracks me up with someone comes I've got
this great idea for an essay I want you
to write I'm like you asked for 12 hours
of my time basically right and and so it
takes me a long time to do something
like that but it's also the thing that I
enjoy most once I once I get it going
you know Ryan and I over the years have
accidentally sort of piled on these
things they're not it's not actual
accident but we didn't plan it this way
we've done it very intentionally we've
decided to say yes to certain things but
it started off as a website where we
were just writing stuff and then
eventually like hey let's write a book
because people kept asking like yeah hey
when are you gonna come out with your
book right you're like what were the
minimalist so let's put out a book and
we've done three books together now and
after that we started touring that was
that became another thing that we
started focusing on or we started
focusing on
doing the podcast a couple years ago and
now that was just when the documentary
is coming out hey this would be a great
way to start talking about the
documentary to get people excited about
it but also answers people questions and
then it turned into this whole other
thing and we're over 100 episodes now of
basically answering people's questions
we do live podcasts in front of crowds
and that was something we didn't expect
at the very beginning I fact I didn't
even like podcasts at the very beginning
but then I started to fall in love with
them a few years ago and realize like oh
like I'm not very good at this but maybe
I could yeah I'm a fairly competent
writer but when we first started
podcasting compared to where we are now
it's a day and night difference I'm sure
you've seen this you yeah and yours is
an extra layer because you interview
people we don't really interview people
because well it's terrifying for me to
think about sitting down and and you get
to that point I remember we were we were
going out interviewing people for the
documentary and quite often like we'd
sit down with some well I Patrick Rowan
I think we sat down for five and a half
hours I think three hours in I heard his
stomach grumbling through my headphones
I was like maybe we should get Patrick
some food and so I think you can do that
for a documentary you can sit there for
five hours and you know you're gonna get
30 great seconds out of that and it
makes for a really compelling
documentary because they don't see the
hundreds if not thousands of hours of
mostly sunrise sunset compilations that
hit the cutting room floor and with a
podcast you can't really do that you're
not going to sit here with us for five
hours and then put out a 30-second video
on whatever the platform would be it it
doesn't make as much sense you actually
have to be you have to have compelling
enough questions but but also you have
to be able to anticipate where the other
person is going and how do you make that
interesting considering the audience and
and all these other things and so Ryan
and I have a good dynamic and in by the
way I think it's part of the reason that
our show is different from a lot of
others is we don't we haven't really
done interviews up to this point
but we listen a lot we listen to what
you know the audience is saying we get
to interact with them whether it's live
or it is like just they call in and they
leave us a voicemail we both kind of
started our podcasts in a very similar
way and that we didn't think it through
we didn't say all right 20 episodes in
this is probably what it's gonna look
like you you didn't have a game plan it
was like hey this this is like a new
medium to get our message across let's
just start it's not it's not a game plan
maybe it's not having an expectation no
expectations yeah yeah so I think you
can plan a little bit but there's two
ways that you could go you could just
over plan to the point where you just
make so many excuses that you never
start it that you're like well I need to
record 10 episodes first that way you
have a little bit of leeway and I can
build into it and I don't have to feel
stressed out and that's great advice if
you're actually gonna follow through
with it for me it was I just need to
make one episode talk about my story
about like the dumbest thing I ever did
as a filmmaker the biggest mistake I
ever had which was quite simply just not
pressing record on a reality TV show
that I shot and I was like I think
somebody might be able to like get a
little bit of get some advice from this
and actually learn from the mistakes
that I've made and I'm like maybe I can
continue along with this and hear from
other people and it just evolved slowly
but I'm really glad that I just I didn't
that I just started and it didn't wait
until everything was perfect the timing
was perfect yeah I'm glad we did that
too I mean you know when Josh and I
started to talk about doing a podcast
that's all it was hey let's start doing
a podcast let's make sure that we set
our standards really really high let's
make sure that we have you know good
equipment and and that we have you know
Sean there to help record it and to
produce it and let's put out the best
podcast that we can but there was no
expectation on how many downloads or
where we would be by episode 10 or 20 I
mean we had the same approach where it
was yeah just one episode at a time so I
guess like entrepreneurial tip number
one is have lower your expectations but
raise your standards because what that
means is if you're putting out your best
work then someone will will enjoy it it
doesn't mean that you know you're gonna
have a million followers on that first
podcast but if you can put out good work
and can
tip number two is be consistent and you
can be consistent with that high quality
at work like that is where more people
will come and they will come back
because they know what to expect they
know it's a good quality show and I mean
that's that's kind of been Josh and i's
approach for everything not just the
podcast but I mean even with the
minimalists comm 52 people showed up
that first month 52 and you know Josh
now we were pretty excited like great
like 52 people came to our website we
got an email or two and it was great to
be able to add value to other people's
lives and then 50 to turn into 500 500
to 5,000 and now you know we're able to
tell her story to millions of people
every year but it was with that same
approach of you know our expectations
were very low but our standards were
super high so let's let's go back to
some of those very early days and I want
to even start before you started the
minimalist and you know you're at that
lonely lunch table senior year of high
school trying to figure out what you
want to do with your life decide to go
down this corporate path and and set
your eyes on making your first $50,000
you know was the corporate path the only
path that you guys saw at that point in
your life and I'm also curious what
success looked like for you as young
fresh green 18 year olds but for me like
I grew up with my dad owning his own
business painting and hanging wallpaper
and he got by but it was just like he
was just barely getting by and I
remember when I graduated high and I
worked I worked for him during high
school during the summers but when I
graduated like my plan was to work for
him and then eventually take over the
business but then I like started to
realize at like 18 19 years old like
wait a minute like I'm putting in like
40 50 hours a week and hardly getting by
myself I don't want to take this
business over and your dad was always
having money problems always while he
owned the big I remember one day when he
was paying his taxes he wrote a letter
to put in this taxes he's like hey I'm
sorry that my taxes are short I had to
feed my family and like just send in a
short check holy cow I know I'm it and
it's but the government never got back
to him either like I don't know if they
let it slide or what but that's amazing
that he wrote them a lot
don't pay he's like here's what I here's
what I have like sorry I defeat my
family but you know when when I
graduated high school college wasn't an
option being raised as one of Jehovah's
Witnesses they do not encourage college
at the end of the world is gonna be here
so why would you go to college that's a
good point how dangerous that mind cells
like growing up as a kid you were
basically told like I don't worry about
it go in the debt forget about College
because you know we're all going to see
the end of the world with the next 10
years I mean there's a lot of I mean
this is totally an aside but there are a
lot of cases like in the late 80s
or maybe early eighties only we'll just
say the 80s know where it was the mid
that organization specifically had this
huge wave of bankruptcies in their
organization because that's exactly yeah
I mean they took out loans more than
what they could afford thinking that
well I'm not gonna have to pay back this
loan I'll just you know go ahead and do
this and Jesus will come and and save
everything and fix everything but anyway
so so college was not an option I
certainly couldn't afford it I never
saved for it I had no idea I had no idea
how to even approach going to college I
remember like when I when I actually did
go to college I started when I was 25
years old and I was talking to my boss
and she this was in the corporate world
because the corporation paid for 100% of
it so I was like well I might as well go
to school they're gonna pay for it now
what's my boss and like hey can you help
me figure out how to go to college and
the look on her face was like she's like
did no one ever sit you down like when
you graduated high school and show you
like how to apply I'm like no like I got
out of high school I started working for
my dad and realize you know two years
into it this sucks I remember telling my
dad I'm like dad you work this much some
days he come ended and he's got this
stress dot above his like right between
his eyes and if you see that dot you
just don't talk to him cuz he's so
stressed to help like blah to your red
skin kind of thing yeah and it's only
this one spot it's really weird right
between his eyes but but my point is is
I remember like seeing that dot one day
and I'm like dad you make X amount of
dollars and you
work x-amount hours a week this doesn't
make sense to me there's got to be
something else out there that we can do
or that I can do and you know eventually
while talking to Josh about what he was
doing and I remember him telling me he
was like I'm selling cellphones I'm like
sweetie I'm like how much money do you
make selling cellphones he's like I
don't know I think this just this month
I made like sixty-five hundred bucks
seven thousand bucks this is back in
2001 and he was in Ohio yeah and he was
and he's you know 20 years old 21 and
I'm like I thought he was lying I'm like
dude no way I blew it off for months and
months maybe even a year so I just
remember I was in Josh's wedding and we
got to you know we were talking more and
more about me doing something different
I hated what I was doing at the time and
finally I was like all right dude I'll
try it out and yeah like that first
month I rep made like actually that's
not true
remember the first couple months it was
like the slow yeah it was just it was
just a really weird time but that first
Commission check I got it was a couple
months later and it was like 4500 bucks
the first thing I did is I went and
bought a new truck I was like sweet man
I could I can afford a down payment yeah
yeah yeah yeah but uh no it was it
wasn't interesting it was an interesting
start to to a new career I mean I was
really excited and you know for all
intensive purposes man I loved it for
the first you know couple few years but
you know it gets it wears on you after a
while what was the question again
I I tried to drop out of high school and
it's my my Kent the counselor you know
the the high school counselor you
basically go to him and talk to him
about why you want to drop out and part
of the reason was like all the friends
and my neighborhood had already dropped
out at least most of them and it's my
senior year and I was just like so done
and I wanted I knew
I wanted to do something in business but
but I also knew that that I I wasn't
going to college route and I'm like this
high school thing is it doesn't make any
sense I'm I was already like 17 at the
time and I wanted to just move on and he
he got to the point where he he wouldn't
let me drop out of high school but I got
he was able to convince me that
basically he could stack my whole
schedule with a bunch of study halls and
I'd take two or three classes to
graduate and he let me take off the
entire second semester of my senior year
of high school because otherwise he knew
I was done but I wasn't gonna go to
college and so I went out and got
full-time job sales job and that's when
I started climbing the corporate ladder
and it was weird I just said yes to this
thing because of money that was the
primary driver we all need to make money
and I said well here was the best
opportunity to make money but I didn't
really know what I was going to do with
the money I thought I was so unhappy
growing up because we didn't have anyone
it really poor food stamps government
assistance and and money would obviously
solve all of my problems if I could just
have enough money then then I would be
happy and then of course I by age 19 I
was making more money than I ever saw my
parents make we're not when I was
growing up my dad wasn't around it was
just my mom raising me and so I had debt
for the first time it's not like I was
making great money I I was more broke
than I was a year prior because I had
these credit cards that showed up in the
mail and I started renting out a nicer
apartment and realized like I was saying
yes to everything that looked appetizing
to my life
right it was it was appealing at the
time and so I in a weird way ended up
sitting in the passenger seat of my own
life where because I had said yes all
these other things like all of a sudden
I wasn't in control anymore like someone
else was driving it was the credit cards
the job that I started working I was
working 80 hours a week and I was really
good at it too and that was another
problem you get all these accolades and
you win these President's Club awards
and they send you off on trips to Hawaii
or London or
and and then they give you these
promotions and you start climbing this
corporate ladder and you get to this
point where it gets scary to look down
so you just keep climbing up and I was
the youngest director in my company's
history by age 27 140 year old telecom
company and I got really close to the
guys I aspired to be like I had a whole
plan in place I was going to be a vice
president by age 32 which is really
young now I was gonna be senior vice
president by age 35 a c-level executive
by age 40 like that was my plan as I as
I was climbing but it all started when I
was 18 and decided I'm gonna go this
path it wasn't a deliberate path it was
just a I'll say yes to this I guess and
I think that's okay especially when
you're young to say yes to a bunch of
things early on but keep questioning
those things and that's where I ran
astray I wasn't question any of it well
this is the path supposed to take I've
already gotten this far and so I'll keep
climbing and but as I got closer to
those guys I really aspired to be like I
really want to be the CFO one day or CEO
o is what I really wanted to be and but
as I got closer to some of these guys I
mean they were miserable heart attacks
and third divorces and and huge money
problems even though they were making
seven figures some of them or really
close to it and then I realized that
well if I follow that same path I'm
gonna end up in the same place I think
we all tell ourselves like well I'll be
different but why if you if you follow
the same recipe you're gonna bake the
same cake as someone else and so that's
kind of where we're where I ended up in
this place of not true discontent but of
a place of dissatisfaction and and it
lacked anything meaningful to me and so
of course I try to pacify myself with
with pleasure basically it sounds like
minimalism came at the perfect time for
you because given the choice at eighteen
years old where it's like hey do you
want all this money right or do you want
minimalism right like I don't think you
would have chosen minimalism at that
point in your life but you've gone
through a lot of experience and you saw
for yourself what worked and what didn't
work
was it that you you knew that you were
to scat discontent or was it minimalism
that helped pull you out of that and
realize that this wasn't for you well
there's nothing wrong with money first
off like I think money can be great it
allows you to accomplish a lot if you
use it deliberately the problem that I
had throughout my 20s is you I grew up
poor and I thought the reason we were
discontented is we didn't have money the
reason we were actually discontented is
we made repeated bad decisions with the
little money that we did have and I just
carried those decisions forward into my
20s had I made good decisions with that
money there was a point in my career oh
it's make a couple hundred thousand
dollars a year and in Dayton Ohio which
we're out in Los Angeles now I don't
can't even imagine what that would be
like like here you its orders of
magnitude different but but the point
being is if I would have made better
decisions with that money then I think I
still could have led a meaningful life
you can be a rich person and live a
meaningful life you can be a poor person
and live a meaningful life I've seen
both sides of of the spectrum minimalism
showed up at the time for me where it
felt like I got into those two car
crashes you know my my marriage ended
my mother died both in the same month
and and and you know it's feels like you
get just t-boned at a light and then
someone else rams into you right after
that but then there was almost like this
after the accident someone Randall over
my foot because I realized like no I
wasn't very contented with with what I
was doing for my corporate career and
it's not that I hated it but it was
comfortable it was a six out of ten and
that was actually part of the problem is
like it it got in the way of everything
meaningful in my life my health my
relationships I wasn't writing like I
wanted to write it I wasn't creating how
I wanted to create I certainly wasn't
contributing in a meaningful way but I
was making a good income I had a nice
house I had several Lexuses and I
realized like Alexis Alexa yeah that's a
good question
I don't know Shawn's not here to look it
up for us
but uh and so you get you get to this
point where you are are comfortable and
you're afraid to lose that comfort and
minimalism was a way for me to realize
that that comfort was a bit of a facade
and a comfort was getting in the way of
what I consider to be meaningful about
your transition out of the the corporate
world what was that decision like for
you and I think back to when I started
as a freelancer and it sounds similar to
you guys where you say you had 50
followers come to your site 50 people
come to your site to read what you had
to say right um I had $100 project every
once in a while every two weeks not
enough right 50 people is likely not
enough though if you're trying to to
spread your message and make a
sustainable looking yeah to make a syst
yeah to to uh to have people to support
you yeah yeah absolutely
okay and we never had a number in our
heads on like how many people I mean in
fact if you were to ask me now like so
what's the number to have a sustainable
audience that can support support you on
a consistent basis like I wouldn't even
be able to tell you okay and it's
probably different for everyone because
yeah people with f50 if you're a a
really well-known artist and you have 50
really good buyers you might be a
multi-millionaire yeah
or if you know Kevin Kelly says you know
thousand true fans or whatever I think
Ryan early on you and I we weren't it
wasn't a business though like it
literally it legitimately wasn't a
business like we we had a domain but we
didn't have you know the LLC or any
hopes to have like a team of people that
we work with and that's why Ryan earlier
was talking about Shonda is our employee
like we don't think of people into those
terms like we're all on the same team
right and and and and I think that early
on it was just like wow this is pretty
cool like some people are getting
something from this and then we learned
like hey maybe we can't make some money
yeah well we didn't I mean we didn't we
didn't charge for anything on our
website for the first year that we had
it I mean it was just us putting up our
essays and it wasn't until yeah
I have people kept asking when you gonna
come out with your book and I'm like
well yeah that makes sense and Josh is
like yeah we're the minimalist we should
write a book on on minimalism so I mean
that was really the first thing we
charged for that book we wrote in I
think it came out December 2011 is that
correct yeah the best sales month that
it ever had it was December 2012 13 13
stars was two years later yeah and that
and so you know just to the point of
like there is no there is no magic
recipe I guess how do you approach risk
because it seems to me that that's a
huge risk you have these jobs where
you're calling for you make a lot of
money and that's the transition question
yeah yeah so how do you deal with that
risk when I sat Josh down and asked him
why the hell are you so happy and he
told me about this thing called
minimalism and introduced me to an
entire community of people who were
minimalist what I saw was some very
common-sense things like oh if I don't
have a six-figure mortgage hanging over
my head if I don't buy a new car every
couple years if I stop racking up all
this credit card debt maybe I won't have
to work 6070 sometimes 80 hours a week
so for me minimalism the the why behind
it was you know why did I want to become
a minimalist when I asked myself that
question how my my life be better with
less like the one thing that really
stood out to me was was my time I could
I could reclaim some of my time so
minimalism
I wasn't like diving into it to be this
you know I'm going to live in a box from
now I'm gonna be a freegan and I'm gonna
go live in a box and you know live live
with as little money as possible I mean
it wasn't about doing it for the sake of
look at me look how uh you know
altruistic I am like Here I am giving up
everything it was more about hey look
here is what I have on my plate now and
if I could find a way to give this up
then I can reclaim some of my time and
maybe start on a better path so it took
me about
about a year year and a half of of
paying off debt of budgeting eating
ramen noodles and peanut butter and
jelly sandwiches which I really wish I
would have done something different back
then it's not the healthiest diet but it
was cheap better than carrot juice I'm
pretty sure that this is gonna be a big
fad now the carrot juice is gonna take
over yeah yeah so so you know we didn't
just quit our jobs and start a blog
that's the worst advice anyone can give
you um it was a very slow transition in
fact I got laid off it wasn't even like
I didn't really have the choice to be
like okay now I have all my ducks in a
row I'm gonna go ahead and quit now I'm
actually grateful I got laid off because
I don't know if I ever would have got to
that point where I would have actually
walked away I mean probably would have
but it would have been much later than
when I got laid off in September 2012 is
that right yeah yeah yeah it sounds like
it's it's about calculated risk so
everybody should take risks and you're
gonna have to take risks in life if
you're gonna do anything worth doing
yeah absolutely
I don't think there's anything wrong
with risk as long as you're making like
you said a calculated risk so when I got
laid off thank God that I had been going
down this minimalist path because at
that point I did have six months worth
of bills saved up I had paid off a lot
of my debt I got rid of my car payment I
had prepared because eventually the plan
was to quit you moved out of your big
house and yeah and rented it out to
someone because you couldn't sell it
exactly so it's so when when I got laid
off yeah I mean it was that wasn't
really taking a risk because I got laid
huh risk is kind of risk is what you can
stomach though right it's like everybody
has a different threshold of what they
can stomach as well I will tell you
though that like the month before I got
laid off I went to my boss and I because
I had got to a point where I felt like
okay if I got late if I lost my job
tomorrow I can survive for at least the
next six months and try and figure out
some things to do so I went to my boss
the month before I got laid off and I
asked and I asked him like hey man if I
ever decide to leave who would you fill
my role with who
you replace me with and we were talking
and eventually he's like you know what
man he's like this this program is
working really well I don't know if I
would if I would replace you and I'm
like huh that's a really interesting
thought isn't it and then a month later
you know I get the Texas hey Ryann meet
me in this conference room where we've
laid off dozens of people before so I
mean you know when I got the text I knew
who it was coming but yeah I mean they
basically hire you know hired me to
build a program in the company I did
that it was it was running well they
didn't need my role anymore but I would
not have had that conversation with him
if I didn't already if I hadn't been
working a plan for the last year and a
half so I think that's where risk is
okay to take like as long as you have a
plan behind it and it is a bit
calculated what I've learned in my life
is that I'm never gonna just fall
completely flat on my face as long as I
I do the pre-work before taking that
risk I think some risks are really
dangerous the problem is we think we
think most things that are risks we
treat out most things like oh my god my
401k slipped by 1/10 of 1% this month
like we have the same reaction to that
well my god like so as we do you know
last night we saw a coyote walking
around like that is a much bigger risk
to me than my my 401k if that thing was
rabid and decides to attack me I have to
trip backs and run faster than her no I
I think that that's the problem with
with risk is we all were often treating
it like like if something is dangerous
for me it was riskier to stay because I
saw what the outcome was when I was
those guys I aspired to be like that's
real risk that going down that route you
know being fat overweight and and just
unhealthy in general but also being
unhappy that's that's pretty risky too
being dissatisfied with the life you're
living like how long you gonna hell are
you gonna do that before it's you start
to look back and ring
the life that you lived and I could see
that right then like I don't regret
spending that time in my 20s learning
what I learned and that was I've learned
a whole lot and I was able to tweeze out
and pull forward but I know if I were to
continue down that path much longer I I
wouldn't have been living the life that
I wanted to live and it's not a perfect
life
I still feel stress and anxiety and and
and there are times where it's really
difficult in fact there are times it's
so difficult where I'm like man it'd be
easier to just go back and work for
someone I don't make all the damn
decisions and and the truth is that when
you look at the aggregate it's so much
better and it's actually less risky now
than what it was before by the way like
staying with where I was ultimately
would have been the biggest risk because
they're required by another company but
by a larger telecom company that ate
them up and and and then you know very
likely I would have been gone in that
transition back in 2014 or whatever and
then if I wouldn't have prepared for it
you know I would have been scrambling to
try to find a similar telecom job and
Providence Rhode Island or something
like just trying to like find whatever I
can get to pay the bills and because I
was still attached to that lifestyle and
that's a real risk it seems like the the
smartest thing that you can do is to
develop and learn skills that aren't
going out of style any time soon so if
you develop becoming a better writer or
if you learn how to become a filmmaker
or a photographer these are all things
that aren't gonna go away very soon
right and it's something that if you can
build something on your own and learn
how to pick up some freelance jobs even
if the economy is doing bad even if
there aren't many jobs you can probably
still pick up some work when you press
record for the first time on a camera
you it's not you're like well I'm
getting paid to do this it had to do
with something you're interested in
something that may be aligned with what
you wanted to do in the future but but
it wasn't about money first and and I
think a lot of these things for for them
to to work out well for us long term
is you want to be able to do it even if
it's not sustainable monetarily but then
you can also look to see does anyone
make money doing this is there anyone
who makes money as a filmmaker is there
anyone who makes money as a writer and
the answer is of course yes and and I
mean you can find someone who is you
know a clown who I mean literally who
dresses up like clowns and makes money
that's what you're passionate about then
great if you're passionate about
teaching horse horseback riding you can
find a way to make a living from that
from from that passion or at least
somewhere that's adjacent to that
passion for me what was a jaitley I
wrote fiction that was the thing I
always wanted to do and now I write a
lot less fiction because we had this
whole beautiful nonfiction real it was
adjacent to what I was already doing and
and for you I mean you started out you
were doing wedding videography farm it I
would do it I was just looking at some
of the old bar mitzva intro videos I
made it's all over the battle on fire
wasn't that like incredible I'm like but
you know what actually I learned and
relearn about how I approach those
projects back in the day is that was a
Bar Mitzvah video there weren't high
expectations but like I use it as an
opportunity to practice color grading to
learn after-effects and how to track
fire onto a baseball bat like I was like
holy cow I probably learned a lot from
that project but you can't just say oh
it's this is just something that's
temporary I feel like anytime you're
developing your skill in your craft you
have to put yourself into it yeah I
think we all we were all born with some
sort of talents but but we often mistake
those talents for skills a skill was
actually developed and you have to spend
time you see so you might have a natural
eye to see lighting or you know the way
that you focus a camera or the way that
you you are filming a particular scene
you might have a natural eye for that
but what makes it beautiful is the skill
of figuring out how to do it most
effectively I think it's the same with
with anything else any other creative
endeavor and not even creative endeavors
like being in the business world like I
learned how to run a business not by
going to some class and reading about
business theory but by opening dozens of
retail stores and
managing hundreds of employees over many
years I messed up a lot I had mentors on
my own but it was on-the-job training it
was much more effective than just going
to a class and and trying to sort of
learn via osmosis or just you can't just
read what's on your page here and then
all of a sudden say well now I know how
to direct a film who doesn't work that
way and it's the same with writing a
book it's the same with with pretty much
any endeavor creative or not yeah there
are only so many entrepreneurial books
you can read before you have to just put
them down and actually try to start a
business and you can get some good sort
of best practices from those but you
still have to implement that in your
everyday life otherwise it's useless
yeah I think it's like you get the the
guiding wisdom and and good mentoring
from that so say if you don't have
mentors in your life that can guide you
in the right way and say hey it's just
it's not always about the bottom line
it's very easy to get caught up in the
rat race of the nine-to-five corporate
world but there is still a rat race
beyond that in the entrepreneurial world
and somebody running their own business
because it can very quickly become about
likes about how many followers you have
about how big your audience is how well
we did this quarter compared to next
quarter how did you guys from the onset
make sure you didn't fall back into that
trap my number one secret is I spend
less money than what I make
so like Josh and I are never comparing
last quarter versus this quarter or last
year versus this year I mean we have an
idea cuz you know we do our taxes but we
don't ever sit down and we're like oh
man you know we made ten thousand bucks
less this year how can we how can we
make that Delta back up this year yeah
push more books yeah and it's funny
Jessica came to so jessica jessica lynn
williams she runs our social media
really fortunate enough to have her she
curates everything so we still interact
on social media but she curates a lot of
the posts and stuff that we yeah we also
bring her on the road to to share some
of our pithy answers when we're doing
live podcasts on stage she live tweets
and stuff and and she came to me early
on
the tour this year you said you know you
guys have just never asked me like about
engagement and clicks and likes just
like how am I supposed to know if I'm
doing well and why are you doing well
and she's like yeah but I think I can
approve this I can prove this and this I
said okay but none of those things have
to do with likes how much of a influence
you have has very little to do with the
counts it's one of the nice things about
Netflix we went to go meet with Netflix
a few months ago and their lay and
secretly we'd love to know how many
people saw the film because you know
it's in the tens of millions at this
point just based on on the amount of
traffic that that has cascaded our way
but you'd love to know like how how's
the film doing what other fit like you
want to get the stats on it right
because mainly because they don't share
it with you in fact the lady said you we
don't even share the numbers with Kevin
Spacey mm-hmm you think we're gonna
share with you and a good point but but
in a weird way that was freeing and and
because we actually run the rest of our
business if you want to call it that the
same way we'll look at our traffic stats
once a year to give to our publicist so
they can say well if they're if they're
reaching out to someone here's what they
get but I'm not looking at the numbers
the Downloads all this other stuff
because you you start to let that
influence the way that you are are
creating if I could just have a more
creative thumbnail and and for this
video or if I could just have a better
title for this and that's why you see
all these vapid click Beatty listicles
or or you must do this the secret to
this the 67 ways to blank and you're
like does anyone really walk away from
that feeling like like they were that
they're a better person after reading it
or do they just feel like oh [ __ ] I just
wasted the last 90 seconds I'm a numbers
guy I love numbers I probably look at
the numbers more than Josh but for me
it's it's numbers are fun so that's one
I like I like looking at them I mean I
partly play fantasy football because I
love the numbers man I love researching
and and doing all the calculations and
figuring out who I should start and you
know so forth and so on
um but those numbers are not the driver
like it is if anything it might be an
indicator so you know might be um you
know if I look at it if I look at a dip
in traffic and you know Josh and I
hadn't put an essay out and you know in
a week or two which I don't think we
have around two weeks without putting
out an essay but but that is an
indicator right
oh okay greatly yeah people aren't just
coming back to our site like they do
want some fresh content um but again
like that's to me it's it's like it's
like when I feel stress I don't just
like sit there and react to the stress
it's more like what is this what is this
telling me is it telling me anything or
like what do I need to focus on so like
I look at numbers that way but I'll tell
you man like you know when I've got to
ten thousand Twitter followers versus
thirty thousand Twitter followers it
doesn't feel any different it wasn't the
key to happiness damn you didn't find it
it's fifty thousand Twitter followers
I remember Josh we had a conversation
early on I was asking it for advice it
was around the same time we were talking
about what to name my podcast and I was
like by the way for those of you listen
to this on the minimalist podcast he
it's called the ground-up show you can
find it on Apple podcast or wherever and
you should check it out if you enjoy
podcast because it is a good podcast so
there's the plug for thank you sir
appreciate video if you want to see me
and Ryan this is all on video right now
as well we'll probably put this up on
our YouTube page as well but he has a
whole mat and that has a whole YouTube
page with all that stuff so yeah ground
up show you can find it yeah so we have
this early conversation and I was just
trying to pick your brain get some
advice about how what can I do because
this is really a time when I was
starting to make original content for
the first time we just put out
minimalism and this is I did freelance
film work for a very long time I loved
it it was great but minimalism was a
chance for me to to get something put
something out that I really cared about
right this was at the top of my bucket
list make a document like literally four
months before
we started the documentary before Josh
emailed me about it it was on my bucket
list I wrote make a documentary about
something I care about something I'm
passionate about and then that email
comes in I'm like oh [ __ ] in my email
and that goes to the thing Ryan was
talking about earlier with with high
standards and low expectations because
we went into making that documentary
with high standards and we all had let's
say heavy opinions about the direction
and where we wanted it to go we went
back and forth and the final version
that ended up in theaters and on Netflix
was like the ninth version and it had
gone through a bunch of iterations there
was a dip there in the middle with the
Fargo and today we went I need to go
into the Fargo incident that was we
thought that Matt just just to recap
look what we thought Matt was like
punking us like it was an early April
Fool's joke or something but yeah he
sent us a cut of the documentary that
actually ended up shaping the direction
of the documentary to be much better
yeah but what he sent us was
terrifyingly bad it was avant-garde I
saw what you were trying to do with it
man so I told her it's what you're going
but yeah but talk about that process how
many times did you Josh and I like how
often did we talk about where the
documentary was going as far as
distribution and what our expectations
were we literally like it was in the
very beginning but I said oh yeah I mean
I just release it through Vimeo put it
like give it to our audience and yeah
yeah we didn't have a specific
expectation is really at the point well
there was no document floating around
that was like we need to get into movie
theaters we need to get with Netflix we
had I mean and we musta Film Festival we
were putting money into it too so but
like if we didn't honestly it was like
yeah if we make our money back that'd be
cool right I don't care I was it I just
want to make this movie I just want to
put it out there this is a chance for me
to actually direct a feature-length
documentary it was more about climbing
the mountain than it was about
you know trying to make money or trying
to reach a certain amount of people well
continue to continue that that metaphor
is more about climbing the mountain than
reaching the summit yeah and and I think
that it was about enjoying the climb
because going through it and it took the
better part of three years from the very
first frame to being out on on Netflix
it was quite the journey and in that
whole time it wasn't because if we would
have had the expectations like well we
want to be in the Toronto Film Festival
and this and this and like we did submit
to a bunch of film festivals and learned
that as a total racket and a waste of
money and we had this great film that
didn't get accepted by a lot of film
festivals but it got accepted by the
most important type of acceptance which
is having an actual audience who enjoys
it and finds that film transformative
and we didn't it wasn't our expectation
to get it on the Netflix it was our high
standards that ended up getting it on
there in the long run in fact they even
said no to the documentary a couple
times and we had to go through you know
sort of third party and work that out
but it it wasn't like well this is a
failure if it doesn't if X Y & Z hat
doesn't happen no it's a success as long
as your standards and I think it's yeah
get ready for a lot of nose because we
like you said we got rejected from a lot
of film festivals a lot of people we
asked that we wanted to interview in the
film said no who are you guys a lot of
like you said Netflix said no in the
beginning you can't let those stop you
from from moving forward
so we put out minimalism and this is you
know my first time putting an original
work out there and I was like this is
cool like I wanted to keep doing this
like this is a lot of fun I really
enjoyed it
so that's why I started the podcast and
also I had a lot of filmmakers asking me
for advice about how we put it together
and I think a lot of people had this
expectation that it's a Netflix
documentary there was 20 people in the
background orchestrating everything
everything was like it was matte with
that camera right there legitimately it
wasn't even the camera that's nice as
that camera yeah yeah it was a
just running around with a camera and
like a lighting kit that filled up about
half of the car we got a photo actually
when I left on tour with you guys with
you posing next to me yes don't miss
though I think yeah yeah if they let it
go it's lighting kit so it was you know
I was like all right how do I do this
Josh like what are some pointers and
advice like I know I need to make
consistent content that's like number
one I just gotta keep putting content
out there oh and then you just stopped
me you're like hmmm I just just wait a
minute
like you have to make meaningful content
it's not about the amount of content you
put out there being consistent important
but you have to consistently make
meaningful content yeah and in fact I I
try to stop using that word altogether
because for me it has a negative
connotation now I realize it doesn't
have to have a negative connotation but
for me in my mind it does because it's
it's so just right when I hear like yeah
it's really about you've got to put more
content out there and in and that's the
internet culture and putting more
content and I try to eschew content and
and instead produce meaningful creations
and so to me it's about producing
meaningful creations not content
creation and I think if you can
delineate the two the question is what
is meaningful to you and doesn't mean
that's gonna be meaningful for everyone
you're still gonna get one star reviews
and thumbs down or whatever else and and
that just means that someone else was
like hey this wasn't for me
and that's okay in fact we have an essay
on our website called this probable
isn't for you
and when someone ever someone leaves
like a a terrible comment or whatever
Jessica will just send them the link to
that essay this probably isn't for you
and that's okay and realizing that is
really freeing because you realize
you're not making something for everyone
it's not vanilla ice cream you want you
want something with your own flavor to
it and not everyone is going to enjoy
the taste of what you're making and I
think that's okay but if you find a
meaningful there's a good chance that
other people will because there's a lot
of other people who are a lot like you
not demographically like you but like
minded and open-minded and and are
asking some of the same questions that
you're asking if you can produce
something meaningful instead of just
trying to produce something for the sake
of producing producing something because
well
it is another Wednesday and I have to
put out another vlog today or its
everyday vlog thing uh-huh and and to me
so there are some people who can do that
really well they can do a daily vlog and
it's really good the vast majority of
the time just like Seth Godin can write
a blog post every day and he is we were
at a conference once and a gal there
Amanda I think her name was of a misfit
she was talking about how she interned
for Seth Godin for awhile and she said
and it was like the best moment my life
because Seth Godin is my Beyonce and I'm
like I kind of feel that way too like in
terms of blogging like not writing in
general there's people that are much
better writers than Seth Godin there is
I can't name another person who's even
as good close to being as good at
blogging assess codon and he's able to
do it every day
and and here's the key it's meaningful
what he produces are meaningful
creations he's not posting every day for
the sake of content creation I think if
he ever got there he'd walk away from
how do you how do you keep up that
consistency and how do you consistently
be good like that seems to be really
challenging to create you know a lot of
his stuff will have some overlap same
with you guys you're talking about
simple living there's only so much that
you can touch on how do you can continue
to make consistently meaningful and good
quality essays that's kind of the answer
to the question like you have to
consistently write because you're
actually consistently getting better
when you when you put forth the effort
yes it's not easily get scan systole
getting better yeah good point man I
feel that that you like even with the
podcast there are some episodes very
recently back in the mid 90s we did the
mid 90s ISM our we're on 100 episodes
gonna say I was like you guys are ahead
we've gained podcasting since the mid
90s great of you who started this
podcast in high school oh man still
running twenty something years when he's
been 20 years man yeah kids out there
start a podcast and keep it going for 20
years yes seriously and we were at the
academy of podcasters convention
recently Ryan is now an academy and not
a nominated Academy Award nominee
Academy Award is it
for the nomination yeah we had our
podcast got not we we lost the the world
do we really nominated is winning Josh
yeah yeah but we were on the list with
like Dan Savage
and yeah just prolific yeah doctor yeah
I'm like I don't even know how we ended
up on that list we joined fellow losers
like Joe Rogan right and ferriss sam
Harris
anyway anyway I find that consistently
do it but also being will here's a
better answer for you being willing to
throw away a lot remember especially
early on for every initially probably
every five podcast we recorded we
published one
and over time it was three and then it
was like two and now even now it's like
we record a podcast in Philadelphia
recently and I don't know that if that
one will ever see the light of day or
maybe our patreon supporters will get to
hear it we'll put it out eventually
later but it wasn't something that I
walked out of there happy with at all
and that was happening a lot early on
especially with the writing so we
published three books together I
published one novel that novel was nine
hundred pages that it's bloated zenith
and and it's 200 pages now and the point
was there's a whole lot that has to hit
the cutting room floor and you you
showed this with a documentary man can
you imagine you have 2,000 hours of
footage from all everything that we did
again most of it being sunsets in Santa
Fe New Mexico yes
messed up sunsets I forget those sunsets
we watch together yeah anyway if you had
to if he just published all 2000 hours
it would be the worst documentary of all
time
that's the Fargo cut Exit Through the
Gift Shop the the first kind of
documentary that that dude made for
Banksy that's so it was so bad it was
good right yeah it was in the context of
one of the best documentaries of all
time access to the gift shop and I feel
that that's the same thing with anything
we do people see the end product and
they're like how hard could it be to
make the 79 minute documentary it's not
a 79 minute documentary
initially its thousands of hours of
footage and you have to figure out the
right bits to curate and I think it's
the same with anything else that you're
doing now different mediums lend
themselves to different types of
communication with our podcast it's we
don't you're not gonna do 479 minute an
interview you're not gonna do 2,000
hours of interviewing but it may mean
that you throw away some podcast it just
didn't work out you rerecord them that's
a Ryan I quite often early on we because
most of our podcasts are on about a
particular topic so we have a topic
budgeting we'd sit there and record to
our podcasts and we'd look at each other
afternoon where it's like that was crap
wasn't it yeah I didn't like it All
Right see you tomorrow we'll come back
answer the same exact questions again
and hopefully it'll be better tomorrow
and if it's not we'll do it again or
maybe we'll set it aside I have a list
of maybe 200 essays that I've started
and are in some various stage of
completion that may never get completed
or that they they may get completed
someday there might be an idea that was
great 7 years ago in fact I was talking
to Andrew Bell about this so we did that
Andrew Bell our podcast he's like our
favorite musician he was on our
Indianapolis podcast which was truly
great he performed a live selling on
there and his new new album took four
years to put together and he said the
first song that the first song he wrote
for it he wrote seven years ago and he
just couldn't find a way to make it work
until the last year and when you ask him
how many how many how many songs did not
make the records only 10 songs or
there's 11 songs in the sub
it's his longest album 11 songs on and
and he's like nothing everything from my
last four years is is here but it took
me it took me sometimes seven years to
get the song right so the way he does it
is he'll put as many years into
something as he needs to make it right
not perfect but make it the best given
the circumstances and the resources that
he has I was just noticing this as I was
working on this project this video we're
working on right now and I'm watching it
back and it always the first cut it's
gonna be a little bit longer it's gonna
be have some extra stuff but you don't
realize it even if you do ten passes
through you don't realize all the extra
stuff that you don't need in it how you
could shape it down
and I was kind of a lot of it's based on
your gut right and your intuition where
if you're looking at a page and you're
reading through it you're like that kind
of that part doesn't really feel right
it doesn't sound right and then what is
it about the process to create a process
where you start to figure out what's
working and what's not
I teach a writing class and one of the
things I have to communicate with
students is you are simultaneously more
interesting and less interesting than
you think and I think it's a problem we
have this fear in our lives like you're
the the video you're talking about the
trailer for we're doing this physical
first physical good we've ever we've
ever done right and so it's a bag and
and what what you're going through there
when you have that four-minute
seven-minute video that you're starting
to whittle down is we get so married to
a particular scene or particularly and
we said I can't I can't divorce myself
from that it and who is a Fitzgerald who
said kill your darlings with respect to
writing and and I think quite often we
have to be willing to let go of anything
that doesn't really move it forward and
make it better and and part of that has
to do with emotional detachment from
from the creation that and that comes
during the editing process you want to
have plenty of emotional attachment up
front to to make that thing as
interesting as possible but then to call
it down to what its essence is to make
it the most beautiful brevity is the
soul of wit to get down to that you
can't remove yourself from and say I'm
willing to delete anything from this one
of the tips that I teach writing
students is one of the things you want
to do is delete your first two
paragraphs and anything you write see if
it makes it better and quite often it
does because we we have too much throat
clearing at the beginning of our writing
and that will happen with any greater
than Deborah mmm that's a really good
point yeah I'm thinking like two of my
most favorite books is uh one of them is
the flinch yeah Julian Smith yeah by
Julian Smith it's an awesome book what
was it like eighty something pages it's
thirty pages yeah I read in a day did
you take the cold shower in it yeah yeah
that's great yeah but but like that was
one that was a very impactful impactful
book I read it in a cold shower
Julian Josh has always got a one-up
everyone yeah and then the other one is
uh oh no it's it's everything you want
or anything you want any Derek severs
yeah bye servers yeah and like that one
is like every line is tweetable yeah
eight pages yeah it's it's it's a weird
thing because I agree that in terms of
like sort of nonfiction books that's
certainly one of my favorite because
it's it's like full of these little Zen
Maxim's almost so that that like you
said they're all sort of tweetable right
and then there are other people like
David Foster Wallace you know probably
the most impressive book I've ever read
and it's just impressive by the fact
that you can if you read a book like
this but then you think about the guy
writing it is Infinite Jest and it's
it's 1,100 pages is like nine point font
it's super dense paragraphs and
sentences go on for pages and every
sentence is beautiful it looks like
every sentence is sculpted and when you
realize that he wrote the book within
three years how how and he was younger
than we are now
oh he's older than you are Matt you're
still in your 20s or lady that's right
I'm not exactly knocking on 40s door yet
but I'm walking down the path toward
toward the screen door at least anyway
you you read something like that and you
realize like what is possible and it's
possible also challenge the audience so
so reading books like whether it's a
flinch or Infinite Jest and in realizing
lay oh oh there is something else it's
possible I'm not I'm not capable of
doing that but what can I get from it
and what I learn from a book like
Infinite Jest is there's a great payoff
at the end but you have to literally
read all eleven hundred pages and take
six months to read this book but but you
can require hard work of your audience
and if if you do so in a in the flinch
is the same way Julian Smith is a guy
who will shake the hell out of you and
you'll thank him afterward for shaking
you most people come up to me and shake
me I want to fight them but but enjoying
for something some somehow he's able to
approach it you're like wow I needed
that thanks and so sometimes it's about
challenging the audience Rob Bell says
you
want to stay one half step ahead of the
audience you don't want to be a step or
two ahead because you're too far and
your ideas are way too out there but if
you're half step ahead of someone it
allows them to want to follow and catch
up there's something beautiful about
being inspired by somebody like say
David Foster Wallace where you will look
at that book and you're like oh man like
I need to step my game up I need to set
my [ __ ] up but then there's also people
that I would see that I'm like well if
they can do it I can do it that's not a
wise start of the podcast I was like I
could do this other people are I could
do it I think you need to be motivated
in both ways to see what's possible and
also to push yourself where you didn't
think you could go yeah I tend not to
compare myself with others just because
I will you know find the people who I
really look up to and it makes me feel
like I have to step my game up and then
you know it'll like make me force
something that I should not have forced
right but yeah but it is good to know
where you're at I mean just as far as
talent and you know honestly that whole
community of people of minimalist that
Josh and introduced me to like they've
been a huge inspiration for you know the
last seven years so you certainly do
need to like read other people's work
and you know if you're a filmmaker then
you should watch a lot of movies and and
see what styles you like and look at
other people's recipes and see if
there's any ingredients that you can
apply to yourself we were talking about
this a couple days ago about
self-reliance and how it's it's changed
over time and how self-reliance used to
be starting a fire building shelter and
maybe being able to fix your car or
change a light bulb
and today it's it's changed pretty
dramatically especially in our digital
age it's it can be about growing an
audience about having a creating a brand
which would be almost like presenting
yourself online how do people perceive
you I'm curious so I want to try to help
and give people advice that are really
starting out on this I say somebody
starting out with zero followers or they
don't have any presence online and they
want to be able to put themselves out
there imagine you guys like there was
some crazy incident somebody hacked into
all your files your website crashed and
then somebody went through like your
computers and burned
all your hard drives are destroyed and
you guys the minimus were gone this sort
of happened recently
yeah thankfully Jeff was around we so we
had a malicious attack on our website
and someone deleted everything yeah it
was it was terrifying but like which of
the tour page I'm like what does it look
like the tour page is deleted yeah and
then it looked like everything was
delete and someone went in deleted
everything like holy cow and like we
just thought it was gone like and and
thankfully Jeff who's our very talented
web developer over at spire he was able
to recover and work for several days
straight to to fix everything and man it
was so shout out to spire media day we
had some kind of tickets go on sale for
it was like the first leg of our tour we
had just announced yeah our tour yes
really hey hey good alessa's now calm it
was just four words to our tour page
basically at the minimalists and people
go there and was just nothing there yeah
and it was like the worst possible time
for that man I tell you I'm so grateful
for going to because I've had a lot of
shitty stuff happen over the last few
years and it's allowed me to deal with
those things a lot better and it could
all blow up tomorrow and know that I
know that I'd be completely fine and I
wouldn't even have the same reaction I
would have had seven years ago or I'd be
throwing stuff across the room and I
mean I'll still get angry but I think it
would be appropriate it would be
appropriate response you know I'm not
gonna be the psychopath they're just who
has no emotional reaction to it but it's
a more sort of tempered reaction to to
the the negative news but what I would
tell someone who's just starting out is
zero followers you're starting the same
place I did you're starting the same
place everyone else does as well and it
gets man I know early on especially the
first year you get really caught up and
oh my god I got to a thousand Twitter
followers or a hundred thousand
Instagram or whatever and it doesn't
mean anything at the end of the day Ryan
said it earlier like ten thousand
followers
I'm gonna make you happy those metrics
mean very little if you're not creating
what you want to create cuz here's the
thing what if what if you did get to a
million followers but you were doing
something that was awful well you just
didn't enjoy doing now you now you're in
a different kind of trapped you walked
away from one you got out of one cage
and you walked into another cage and and
and even if it's a prettier cage it's
then you enjoy the cage a little bit
more it's still a cage and and if you're
trapped by what you're you're the size
of your audience is I mean Freud would
have a lot to say about that I do I
completely agree with you on all fronts
what's difficult and challenging as a
creator is that when you you build an
audience and obviously like I don't
think just looking at the numbers like
we said is an unhealthy thing to do and
it's not it shouldn't be the end goal
period I don't yeah I'm having but also
but having an an audience and having say
10,000 20,000 Twitter followers whatever
it is in a way it is clout and and so if
I could develop a bigger audience I
could get bigger guests on my show I
could get interesting people on my show
wouldn't be as challenging to find new
guests so there are doors that open when
you to have a following and I think
that's what's tough is that that that
balancing act between not caring about
how many followers you have because you
really want to focus on what you want to
make and you're doing it because you
really love it and also knowing that it
will be and could be beneficial to grow
this audience and to also impact more
people and change lives yeah if you've
got a million Twitter followers and you
go to you know someone and say hey we do
want to be on my podcast yes like
they're more of a more likely to look at
your followers I'm like oh you've got a
million Twitter followers true I would
love to be introduced to your audience
so yeah I think that is certainly
certainly true where it does open doors
but like you said it is I don't think
it's necessarily unhealthy to look at
numbers but it can certainly be
unhealthy to look at those numbers
because if you start working for the
numbers well you're not working for
yourself anymore mm-hm
and that is a really
it's a really fast way to kill anybody
any passion I feel like a lot of times
you try to think about the big picture
and where you want to go with something
but at the end of the day it's just you
on the desk writing or editing or making
that video or or producing what you
really enjoy so it's like yeah you can
look at that and you can stress out
about it if you want but you looking at
it and paying attention to it and say if
it's a problem that you don't have a lot
of followers it's actually not gonna
help anything
no well and so if you were to take a
photo of rainbow in black and white
that's kind of like looking at the
number if that's all you do is look at
the numbers and that that's how how you
steer it's like trying to look at a
rainbow and grayscale but you're missing
out on all the other things that make
make the creation beautiful and you're
right it may be easier you know Ryan was
saying if you have a million Twitter
followers you can get an interview with
you know you might be able to get the
rock get it bring that up I don't know
if the cameras could totally see it so
Matt really wants to get the rock on his
podcast and here's the thing I don't
know if you had a million Twitter
followers that would even matter to him
at all so here it may even turn him away
it may it may turn him all from layouts
another big podcast who cares but here's
the thing we turned down interviews all
the time of people who have tons of
followers in lines because we have to
say no to a lot of swings say yes to the
most important things however there are
occasionally people who come to me and
and you know it's like I'm working on
this PhD dissertation on minimalism and
here's why it would be really important
to have you involved in this and they
don't have any Twitter followers
anything but there's a compelling case
to make and I think the point is that
yes it may it may remove some friction
to have to have more of those followers
but I'm worried less about removing
friction
I'm worried more about gaining traction
and and what you know you need a little
bit of friction to create that traction
so you talked about having those
challenges yeah some of those challenges
are what makes the thing interesting
yeah I think limitations breed
creativity it's one of the reasons I
think the documentary turned out so well
and if we would have a 20 million dollar
budget to make the document or help you
1 million dollar budget to make the
documentary we I don't know that we
would have made as good of a final
product we may have we may have not
because it wouldn't have been the same
sort of bootstrap thing that it was it
may not had the same essence and they
have looked you know amazing and you may
I don't know you had some flaming
baseball bats in it or something
yeah yeah but but it it may have may
have lost what made it what made it
beautiful yeah and I'm glad that you
brought up the rock because this this to
me is is it's kind of just a crazy
unrealistic goal look why would the rock
want to come on my podcast you guys seem
to do a pretty good job of getting your
message out there and and sharing it and
in what way do you think I could get the
rock on this podcast I come over to my
apartment and like literally it'd just
be me and him and have a conversation
about how he built his so you know I
think for Josh and I um you know
thinking about the documentary and how
we were able to get people like you know
Sam Harris and Dan Harris to be on the
in the documentary it's because like we
had something to offer them it wasn't
just hey will you be on my show to help
my show be you know but to have more
clout or so I can get more listeners it
was hey we have an audience
this is our first feature-length
documentary you know we have high
standards we don't really have any
expectations but but it's gonna be a
great film would you like to be part of
this we'd love to introduce you to our
audience so I don't think there's
anything wrong with asking but it's kind
of the problem with you Millennials man
you think you can just ask for it yeah
in part of the thing is like the the
Ryan left out there is that you add
value first and so giving examples with
sam harris and dan harris in particular
they both have books come out in 2014
and i said i reached out to both of them
said hey we we would love to review your
book for you and and give you a giving
honest review I'd love to do an
interview with you about it as well and
don't want anything in return just want
to be able to give this to to our
audience because I found value in both
of your books
you know up and 10% happier and and I
said great and then they saw that it got
a good response and then it made them
more willing to to do something like the
duck you Mike the documentary and now by
the way the documentary has done so well
for them you know Dan Harris we were
with him in New York couple weeks ago
and he said I've never been recognized
from more from one media thing in mind
and he's a guy was on TV five six days a
week
yes I've never been recognized more from
one thing I was talking to Sam about
this and Sam said the same thing yeah
yeah and Sam that's amazing email me
last one he's like hey can I get a copy
of your writer for the tour so I'd like
to make sure I'm doing this tutorial I'm
doing correctly and so like it's about
adding value but here's here's here's
the key without any expectation of
getting something back it's not quid pro
quo because here's the other thing
that's a secret minh to be able to add
value to someone's someone's life and
and realize that you may not get the
same amount of value back but but you
may like for me like the David Foster
Wallace thing we talked about earlier
there's literally no way I can pay him
back he's no longer alive and by the way
even if he was alive yeah Mary Karr is
another writer who I really look up to I
think her work is phenomenal I think
she's the best memoir us to ever live
and and I look at her writing there's
nothing I could do that would add more
value to her life then then she's added
to my life in terms of shaping my
writing and so the only thing I can do
is try to add value to other people's
lives and stuff yeah so so like when it
comes to the rock the the question isn't
like how can I come up with this hashtag
campaign yeah to get the rocks attention
like the best way to get someone's
attention is to add value to their lives
yeah and there is a hashtag though it's
called get the rock on that spot same
website get the rock on Matt's podcast
calm but I actually did buy it as $20 I
ever spent it sold but I think you I
actually I got a really good idea I
think from just this conversation and
and my takeaway is make the rock smile
and that's like my bare minimum is like
I want to touch the rock not literally
that would be creepy
get that into a three-second video I
keep doing this I keep like I get I
gotta watch out for those sound bites
they'll get ya
so you left off it you wanted to touch
the rock I wouldn't touch the rock
emotionally but like so if I can make a
video in some way that he sees that
makes him smile that makes him laugh
because like what like I I'm not gonna
do anything you know his career isn't
gonna be made when he comes on my
podcast like there's not I don't have
that value to add but there's maybe
something else that I can give him yeah
yeah making somebody laugh like that is
totally adding value I mean that's that
is one step closer than just my brother
my brother suggested that I interview an
actual codfish cuz I know if you guys
know but he eats like 8 pounds of cod
fish every day just like maybe I could
do that like understand the enemy
there's just me talking to a fish
there's a lot of ideas I'm pretty
excited but you guys have really figured
out a way which I'm still learning to
balance creating meaningful work and
also having really healthy productive
habits in your personal lives and and
like it seems like there's a really
beautiful blend between your personal
work lives where it's almost like you
couldn't even draw the line what are
some of the the I guess most helpful
habits you guys have developed I think
work-life balance is sort of overrated
in many ways because it presupposes that
you have like two different selves and
they're sitting in separate offices or
something like well here's my and and
that was actually a big problem for me
when I was in my 20s I had professional
jfm and then personal jfm and for me it
was like the personal side I wanted to I
wanted to be a writer I wanted to write
and I did that whenever I had spare time
but of course you wouldn't talk about
that in the corporate world because in a
weird way they almost discouraged that
kind of creativity like well why are you
doing that seems like a waste of time
why don't you spend more time networking
or whatever and and what I realized like
that was unhealthy for me to have these
two separate selves and so now it's more
about being integrated so you can call
it work-life balance or whatever but the
use of the word habits or
and I agree that I have some some pretty
good habits but I think it goes back to
Orion was just saying is a lot of it
just has to do was saying managing your
time and so for me that just means
saying no to virtually everything
usually we do only we'll do only like
one sort of media thing a week we're
doing we're actually doing three this
week i we said yes the three which is a
very rare thing we spoke at Google
yesterday and we're doing Today Show
later this afternoon for the Australian
tour so Australia today's show and then
we're doing the ground-up podcast yeah
it's an up and coming podcast I've heard
about it is you hear that the rock the
ground up show you got to do Matt's
podcast anyway
anyway so so I'll say no it's a whole
lot because I know what I'm saying yes
to and if I think it really clear on
what you're saying yes to it by the way
I still screw up all the time I
accidentally say yes to things I should
have said no to and even though I'll say
yes to something and it I will do an
interview somewhere and I'm like how
that was supposed to be way different
from what it how it was pitched to us
and had I had all the relevant data I
would have said no to this thing but you
lesson learned and you you move on and I
try to incorporate that lesson going
forward but what questions to ask next
time you know we've certainly had that
oven so I think it's weird like when we
first started we said yes to virtually
everything I think it's about saying
until you reach this Delta where you
have to start saying no and so it was
yes yes anyone if someone had two
Twitter followers want to interview me
like yeah yeah someone wants to listen
to me great yes yes yes yes yes I'll say
yes as much as I can because I'm growing
I'm learning from that from that
experience but eventually you get to a
point where you have to start saying no
and then you figure out what you're
saying yes to one of the most important
things if first it's important to say
yes as much as you can just to sort of
build up that that that creative ability
to I mean if you're doing a podcast you
want to be able to interview other
people so it's a yes yes yes until you
get good at that aesthetic one day you
know Charlie Rose didn't become Charlie
Rose overnight and now he has to be
selective who he says yes to
because it can negatively impact his
show if he's saying yes to anyone who
just on the street who wants to be
interviewed yeah III think I don't know
if this is a habit as much as it is a
tool but do my calendar is like that's
my Bible I mean at the beginning of
every week
Martin Mariah and I we will look at our
week and be like okay let's plan on our
week and then every night before I go to
bed I am looking at that and if I don't
use my calendar I will double booked
myself I will be late to stuff I won't
even show up to stuff mm-hmm I mean I
had to learn that lesson that hard
lesson many times before I finally
started treating me Islander like my
Bible yeah that's like one of those the
very unsexy things about
entrepreneurship and running your own
business and I mean even if you're
trying to keep track of your personal
life you gotta have a calendar and I
recently did it where I had different
Google accounts I have my personal my
business and I had like a separate one
like another my personal website and was
like all three of these and my calendars
were different on each and then I just
took an entire day where I'm like I need
to get this [ __ ] straight I'm gonna go
through and I'm gonna combine all this
things I'm gonna set forwarding filters
so if somebody emails my business it
still comes into my main inbox but it
comes into a separate folder and it's
organized nice nice and neat away I do
the same thing with my calendars and let
the peace of mind I have now to know
that I'm not confused with what I'm
doing this week what I'm doing later
today is super helpful it takes away it
takes away a lot of stress it it makes
room for other good stresses I guess
yeah like the actual creative pursuits
you're trying to do no I think talking
about the banality of being an
entrepreneur that was really really
important because you know you set the
beginning of this podcast you know I'm
sure people want to do what you do and I
have you mentoring students who will say
man I just teach me to do what you do
and I'm like I don't know if you want to
do what I do because you know what what
most people see is we're here we'll hear
this recording they'll see the video the
watch the documentary they they don't
understand all of the banal things that
have to be done in order to make all
that happen something as simple as
making sure that your calendar is
straight and that you are committing to
it and use
that calendar to enter in every single
appointment whether it's business or
whether it's you know going to - I mean
there was a point where I literally I'm
gonna work out I'm going to read I'm
going to write I'm going to you know
have a mentoring client I don't I'm not
as militant with it now meaning like I
if I have a free block I there are three
things and I'm gonna do with the free
block I'm gonna read I'm gonna write or
I'm gonna go work out so I just you know
I will keep that keep those blocks open
during the week but my point is is that
Josh and I we still work some some weeks
will still work 6070 hours and it's
really really tough like we're living
the dream but the catch with living the
dream is you have to work your ass off
and those banal things are are part of
that on that note let's get two quick
questions it's the one and only segment
of this podcast where I ask questions
quickly and you guys just answer them
however you want I haven't I got to
really come up with a good catchphrase
to introduce it but that's basically how
it goes we call it the lightning round
on our podcast so since we're cross
publishing this we'll call this the
hashtag ask the minimalist lightning
round this is where we answer questions
from social media we're at the
minimalists on Twitter Facebook and
Instagram fantastic see you guys you
guys have been doing this over 100
episodes I'm only about thirty in right
now by the way we call these minimal
Maxim's just set up a website called
minimal Maxim's com so all of our pithy
answers they're less 140 characters you
can find them all right there as well
that's great let's do that will keep it
pithy come on these quick questions
question number one what's the simplest
advice that's the most important to
follow you can't change the people
around you but you can change the people
around you dude if there's one message
that Josh and I are really trying to get
people to understand it would be this
love people and use things because the
opposite never works let's say somebody
stuck in a career that they they're
really not happy with they're not
fulfilled we're talking to that person
what can they do today to turn their
life around to start in the right
direction the most important thing for
that person
they probably know what they need to do
they need to do it I mean a lot of my
mentoring students you know when they
when they come to me and they're like oh
I want to I want to paint and I want to
finish this book but I'm also working
full-time and then like I will talk
through to them pick one thing to focus
on and actually put in the work yeah if
I was just a pin that a little bit I
would say don't just know what you want
to know what what you want to do know
why you want to do it and and quite
often we think we want to do something
we don't realize the why behind it and
that is and therefore we lose the
leverage long term if we if we if we
don't know why we're doing what we're
doing
we'll keep doing it for a while but like
I said earlier you end up in the
passenger seat of your own life and all
of a sudden you're like well wait a
minute
I'm not in control of this thing I'm
doing this thing I thought I was
supposed to do but I don't even know why
I'm doing this so get clear on the why
yeah I just realized that for myself and
it came with a simple habit as waking up
early so waking up early is one of those
things that I've struggled with my
entire life especially as a filmmaker a
freelance filmmaker I always wanted to
be the person to wake up early and when
I did I loved it we're gonna Pat 5 6
a.m. was just I felt so productive I got
more done by 11 a.m. that I did most
days most weeks combined I wish I could
sleep in till 6 a.m. but then recently
past two months I've been waking up at
5:00 5:30 a.m. every single day without
fail and it's because I got clear on the
why it was because I was I had work to
do every day that I was passionate about
because I wake up thinking about that I
wake up I'm like oh I want to sit down
at my desk and start working on it it
would yeah and then honestly that's the
biggest thing before I didn't have
anything I wake up and I would have no
work to do I'd have nothing that I was
passionate about and I would just hit
the snooze button and eventually go back
to bed
there was nothing compelling enough to
to make you get there so that's the
other thing find something compelling
and that's usually within the why whoo
that's pithy that's good write that down
podcast shown wherever you are right now
where do you guys go when you're feeling
doubt I can say where I went recently
like literally there's a physical place
I wanted so we just moved out to to Los
Angeles I don't have a lot of health
issues the last couple years and we
started running this up
apartment but I've been I have weird
chemical sensitivities and so we can't
stay there and I was all alone
one week I just went out to the museum
Blacula down the street and just walked
around and lay like because you know
it's it's you're not supposed to like
have your phone out and all these other
things and like it was like this place
of intentional distraction but it
allowed sort of my mind to wander in a
way where it wasn't meditation but it
was meditative in a way and sort of
clear my thoughts when I was back in
Ohio it was where I would I would just
walk around there was a neighborhood
that I would walk around all the time
and and develop a pattern of sort of
thinking okay so I find for me that that
you can't think your way out of problems
but if you need to collect your thoughts
first having going out for a long walk
like five six eight mile walk allows me
to collect those thoughts yeah I mean I
have the type of mind that like when I
leave here when we're done with this
podcast he's a really good brain yeah
the best words I'm gonna start yeah I'm
gonna start in a roasting over it like
now I'm gonna be like man I shoulda said
this I ramble too much and I said that
oh man is that one thing I I can kind of
create my own reality in a way meaning
if I walk away from here and I say this
was a shitty interview or this that was
a shitty podcast Ryan you really did a
bad job guess what that's gonna be true
if I walk away and I say hey you know
what man maybe it wasn't the perfect
podcast but there was some really good
points from it and it was fun we had a
good time and you know what there's
gonna be someone out there to get
something out of it that's also true so
what I've been able to do over the last
like seven eight years is really learn
how to control that muscle it started
with um like a rubber band type thing
flicking myself on the wrist when I
would get negative thoughts or there's
this thing called the pavlok that'll
like give you a little bit of a shock
for you know if you're trying to break a
habit but I would I would literally
catch myself in those thoughts and do
something like that and then try to
redirect what those thoughts are now
what I'll also say is that anytime I do
feel doubt I will acknowledge it
I don't just pretend that Lake Ryan you
shouldn't doubt yourself just think
positive you're not lying tears all
right I'm not lying to myself it's about
looking at that
doubt and and being able to confront it
head-on and either take something away
learn something from it or be able to
like look at that doubt and just kind of
plow through and be like do this doubt
is not serving me any purpose so where
do I go I guess I just go to a rubber
band I don't know I think you brought up
something that was important there when
you're talking about don't lie to
yourself way that I could I fight faced
the same thing and sometimes those
negative emotions are productive so it's
not I don't to lie to myself everything
is positive everything I do is great
every time my quill touches the page I
write something that is legendary no the
truth is most of the stuff I write is
garbage literally like I have to throw
it away it reaches the trashcan and
that's okay because it requires that
sort of plethora of sediment if you're
going to pan for gold there's going to
be a lot of sediment before you find
find the gold and that's that's pity
it's that's tweetable right there and
and so I think it's important not to lie
to ourselves and say man everything is
great great great but at the same time I
think we lie to ourselves the other the
other way to write that was off
everything so bad it was terrible
no it wasn't awful the truth is it was
okay and and what can I learn from the
fact that it was okay let's not lie to
ourselves on either side of it right
what drives you why do you put in the
work it's it's a net positive like
that's but the work that I do will
always be a net positive and you know
what I mean is like it's it's rough
being on tour it's rough going from one
city do you know getting there if a few
hours before the show do a soundcheck go
get dinner do the show go to bed at
midnight get up at 6:00 a.m. rinse
repeat for you know two three four days
in a row but when we get there when we
get onstage you know when we have the
hug line and you can just see how how
positive Josh and I have influenced
people like for me like that is what
makes it it makes it worthwhile that is
why I will put in
the work now if Josh and I were putting
in all this work and no one was showing
up and even though we thought it was
really meaningful work you know we had
zero people attending like then it would
be a net negative like okay this work
that we're doing isn't doing anything
but man yet for me it's about it's about
the work that I put in each day I just
want it to be a net positive and for me
that means that ultimately what I do
aligns with with my values and beliefs
that all those short-term actions all
those difficult the banal things that we
have to do as entrepreneurs it all
aligns with my long-term values and
beliefs and like that for me is how I
live a meaningful life I think I think
the thing that drives me it has those
two things actually and the
contradictory one is is improving
so improving whatever I'm doing so
writing is one example like I was a
pretty good writer in my 20s in fact
their parts in the novel are oh it's
called as a decade fades and I don't
recommend people read it but it's there
are parts in there that are better than
anything I could write right now because
it was a different mind frame and I
spent many years like chiseling away
certain paragraphs and pages and in
their parts that are truly gorgeous that
I'm just not in that mind frame anymore
but as a writer overall I'm leaps and
bounds better than that that bit of work
that was created throughout my my
mid-20s and and I've continued to
improve so you can call it growth you
can call personal development whatever
I'll just call it improvement for the
sake of this and wanting to improve
wanting to get better not to get perfect
but but but to to become better than
what I was yesterday
and whatever that creative endeavor is
so podcasting was a low-hanging fruit
because we weren't we were pretty bad at
it at first we were good at answering
questions and we had done a lot of
interviews but when you become a
broadcaster I'm just talking to Becks
about this the other day like there are
some people who were really great public
speakers and it doesn't translate well
to podcasting because podcasting is a
type of broadcasting and you need to
have broadcasting chops and you turn
these microphones on and it becomes a
totally different a different thing and
it's not as solitary as right
there requires this more direct
one-on-one experience it's still
communicate communicative to an audience
but but it's different I want to get
better at something like that we're on
tour like getting better at public
speaking there's one thing that
terrified me for the longest time and it
doesn't anymore but it was about getting
better at that the other thing that
drives me is a service like being able
to contribute to other people and and
whether that's through our books or
website or podcasts or the live events
it's it's about finding a way to
contribute to other people I think it
almost sounds like a truism the giving
is living but but when you when you find
the ways to contribute to other people
you know we're doing some stuff with the
hurricane relief efforts in Houston and
then also donating personally to the
Puerto Rico stuff and then what's cool
going on in Vegas we're trying to set up
a vent for that with everything that
happened with the the the shooting the
mass shooting and in Vegas finding ways
to contribute like that
- after tragedies but also just trying
to contribute to people in general find
ways to serve them and make make their
lives better and we're able to death
through our message and I'm grateful for
that
yeah I'll say like in the corporate
world the one thing I loved about my job
it was it was the mentoring it was
taking that that employee who was
getting ready to get fired and then
helping them turn it around two or three
months later they were getting Employee
of the Month like helping someone to
make a significant change in their lives
like that is the one thing absolutely
loved and that is pretty much my job now
really we've got two bonus questions
yeah yeah so Ryan and I we we think
advertisements suck and so we refuse to
color our podcast with advertisements
even though this is a weird thing to say
we have one of the largest podcasts in
the world and I was just listening to
Sam Harris recently and he was talking
about how advertising is actually part
of the problem with the media landscape
these days and is directing content in
particular ways and that is a problem is
directing content
and getting in the way of meaningful
creations and so Ryan and I refuse to
cut our our podcast with with
advertisement so each week what we've
been doing we for our patreon supporters
we record a separate podcast just for
those patreon supporters so Ryan and I
are in the middle of building a podcast
and film studio so the reason we moved
out to Los Angeles but because we're not
doing any advertisements we need some
support from our audience we're looking
for 1% of our audience to contribute
just a couple bucks I know it doesn't
sound like a lot to you but it helps us
out a whole lot if you can contribute a
couple bucks just head on over to the
minimalists com click on the donate
button at the top you can contribute one
time via PayPal or venmo or you can
contribute on a per episode basis via
patreon if you contribute via patreon we
have a separate patreon feed and now it
shows up right in your regular podcast
player so if you have Apple podcasts or
you have you have overcast or you have a
feedly or any of these other podcast
apps it just shows up the minimalists
private podcast and will will fade to
black and record one of these private
podcasts for our patreon audience
alright on that note thank you guys so
much for being on the podcast fun men
this really has been a dream come true
for you yeah really has this is gonna go
in my memoir it's gonna be a page one
but I'm gonna make sure to cut out the
first two paragraphs yes yeah it once
again thanks again for coming on one
last thing I do with every guest where
should people go to connect with you
well we're on tour right now so if you
want to come see us in Australia and New
Zealand we just announced that les is
now calm is the tour page the
minimalists column is always the best
place to find our books podcasts essays
and instagrams
Twitter's all that fun stuff Yik yak are
we on Yik yak yeah I think I know I
don't even know what you CAC is I just
hear people say it and then I say it
anyway
alright guys thank you alright thanks
every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that you
need every little thing that's just
feeding your green oh I bet that you'll
be fine without him
oh I bet you'd be fine
I bet that you decide
[Music]
you